this is gonna be a constant challenge I
don't think this goes away until we get
to a vaccine I think there's always
gonna be cases I think you're gonna have
to see spikes in cases and flare-ups
that are gonna be on a regional basis
every part of the country is vulnerable
to an outbreak and this is gonna become
a fact of life that we're just gonna
learn to live with five weeks have
passed since President Trump issued his
stay at home recommendations in the
fight against coronavirus we've all been
a part of this global pandemic and have
played a role in lowering the curve it's
now time to look forward and reopen the
country as quickly and safely as
possible to do this the president formed
the opening our country council and
invited thought leaders from different
backgrounds and industries to come
together to work out a solution to get
everyone back to school and work we're
joined today by two members of that
council they're gonna walk us through
the policy and action behind the complex
and urgent need to reopen the economy we
will be talking about how to save
businesses all over the country how
accurate our testing has been how
conservatives should be thinking about
the stimulus packages the number of
asymptomatic coronavirus carriers the
deception from China our consequence is
to expect from the lock down and a whole
lot more
[Music]
dr. Scott Lee is the former commissioner
of the Food and Drug Administration he's
a resident fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute where he and
colleagues wrote the report national
coronavirus response a roadmap to
reopening which many state and federal
government officials have looked to dr.
Gottlieb has been a leading voice on the
corona virus pandemic he serves on
Maryland governor Larry Hogan's
coronavirus response team and he's been
an advisor to the White House during
this time now before we get started I
just want to remind you and everybody
that we will be asking dr. Gottlieb a
few bonus questions you hear those
answers head on over to Daley wire.com
become a member you can hear the rest of
our conversation over there dr. Gottlieb
thanks so much for joining us you've
been focusing a lot for months and
months and months going all the way back
to January you were one of the first
people who is actually calling for
serious measures and you really focused
a lot on testing so I wanted to ask you
because I really have some questions
about what testing can accomplish so for
example let's start with temperature
test there's been a lot of talk about
people doing temperature tests when
people walk into restaurants or into
their place of business and since we now
know that that kovat is actually most
transmissible when asymptomatic our
temperature tests even a useful gauge at
this point limited utility I mean you
make it you make the right point there
are limited utility you're gonna catch
some people but by and large people are
infectious even when they're
asymptomatic and there's been some
research recently published this week
showing that some people or a lot of
people might be most symptom most
infectious when they are before they
have symptoms so when they're
asymptomatic before they develop
symptoms or when they just develop
symptoms and that's unusual for a virus
typically your most infectious after you
develop symptoms so this this virus is
really designed itself to be maximally
infectious so the temperature checks are
going to be of limited value but there's
some value and if you're thinking of
creating you know a framework where you
have multiple layers of protection that
are least intrusive as possible the
temperature check so one element of that
so there are two other types to test I
want to ask you about one is the the the
antibody tests the the blood test so
those tests testing for antibodies
presumably it takes a little while for
the antibodies to actually develop it
takes several days for antibodies
develop for the virus so you do you have
the same sort of problem with antibody
tests that you would have for for
temperature test namely that if we test
antibodies in a place of business that
well may be good because it may tell us
whether you now have a certain level of
immunity although we're not sure what
level of immunity you have it's it's
gonna be late on the game meaning we
test you it comes up negative because
you don't have the antibodies you're
still a symptomatic so you're still
passing it around the workplace that's
right I mean the antibody tests
typically tell you what's happened it
doesn't tell you what's happening or
what's going to happen so you're testing
for two different kinds of antibodies
IgM and IgG the early antibodies that
you get in response to an infection
might take upwards of five days to
develop them sometimes longer sometimes
less but the antibody tests themselves
aren't that sensitive so you need to
develop a certain level of antibodies to
actually be detectable and their long
term antibodies which is what really
confers long term immunity those don't
develop until well into the infection so
by that time you've probably cleared the
infection and so if you were infectious
and spread the infection around that's
already come and come and gone and so
that what the antibody tests are good
for is to tell you from a public health
standpoint how much infection there has
been in the community so you can look at
different communities people from
different work backgrounds and tell how
much of the infection has passed through
those communities or those jobs and that
can help inform public health decision
making and we're going to find a lot of
variability some parts of the country
where this has been epidemic we're
probably going to find that the exposure
has been pretty high parts of New York
City Staten Island Queens but on the
whole probably the exposure to kovat 19
across the United States is relatively
low probably around 5% and there was
some data out today suggesting that's in
fact the case dr. Gotlieb the third type
of test that's been used is a test
actually I had my son tested for it
because he came down with some some
fairly high fever for about a week thank
God it turned up negative but that test
is the the kind of general test that
people seem to be talking about there
are a few different versions that have
been talked about how fast are these
tests in the turnaround time how
accurate are the tests also because
early on we were told that these things
could be wrong 20% of the time so you
could be testing negative in your
actually positive or you could test
false positive and you're actually
negative for it so how accurate are the
tests and how fast is the turnaround
time on this sort of test we're talking
about that are supposed to test for
contemporaneous for a contemporaneous
presence of Kovan 19:00 right so these
tests are real time PCR and what you're
doing with these tests is you're
amplifying or making copies of the
viruses RNA
genetic material and then you're trying
to detect that RNA and match it against
probes that you have that are specific
to the corona virus to this novel
coronavirus these tests can be
relatively fast some of the machines
that our point of care Diagnostics I
might sit in a doctor's office can
return results within let's say 45
minutes things like the sefie gene
expert platform others might take longer
where you have to run the tests
overnight or it might take a few days
and the reason is is because to run
these platforms you do something called
multiplex which is you run multiple
tests at the same time and you do that
for efficiency and so you might if
you're a laboratory you might need to
get 100 or 200 samples and all run them
all simultaneously so you need to wait
for the samples to come in so that's why
sometimes there's delays and getting
back results and so oftentimes you have
to wait overnight to get results the
academic labs which are adjacent to
hospitals the laboratories that the
hospitals stand up those often times
return results the same day and some of
the big laboratories like quest and
LabCorp when you put a rush on those
tests you can oftentimes get back
results the same day if you need it for
decision-making in a healthcare setting
okay so I want to ask you a couple
questions in a second about antibody
testing first of all I want to ask you
what a testing regimen would actually
look like across the country and second
whether a lot more people actually have
covered 19 then we have previously
thought we'll get to all that in a
second but first I want to take a moment
to give a shout out to all our
advertising partners who help make this
show possible we are super grateful that
they decide to work with us and we
definitely appreciate our listeners
going out and patronizing our sponsors
and keeping all of this going really
appreciate both our listeners and our
advertisers we're all trying to get
through this together you me my shows
advertising partner so let's stick
together and get through this thing
let's talk about the fact that if you
are not actively protecting your data
online there are a lot of bad people who
can grab that data expressvpn will not
allow people to grab that data right now
is a great time for hackers everybody's
online nearly all the time you're doing
all your shopping online all it takes is
a hacker grabbing your credit card
number to make your life miserable don't
let it happen instead go grab expressvpn
expressvpn has developed a technology
it's called trusted server that makes it
impossible for their servers to log any
of your info let alone hackers or other
internet companies a lot of other VPNs
will slow your connection or make your
device sluggish I've been using
expressvpn my internet speeds blazing
fast even when I connect to servers
thousands of miles
way I can still stream HD quality videos
with zero lag the last thing that sets
expressvpn apart really easy to use you
install it on your computer with one
click you are now protected it is super
simple to do all of this you fire up the
app you click one button to connect and
you're done
Grandma and Grandpa can do it too
TechRadar the verge seen at other tech
experts right expressvpn the number one
VPN on planet earth there is a reason
for that you must protect your data this
year protect yourself with the VPN I use
entrust use my link expressvpn comm
slash then today get an extra three
months for free on one-year package
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been
expressvpn comm slash been to learn more
again that's expressed VPN comm slash
been so this is this leads to kind of
two paths of questions that I wanted to
ask you about and one is what can we
actually expect from a testing regimen
and the other is looking at the
prevalence of Kovan 19 antibodies in the
population and newton reference to study
that came out today the the santa clara
study that talks about the prevalence of
antibodies in santa clara which is
multiple times like as in 50 to 85 times
according to them the number of cases
present in santa clara that were
actually identified and what does that
mean for public health so I wanna start
with the first question which is what
are the limitations of testing we've
heard if we ramp up testing to 750,000
or a million tests a day that this is
going to lower the the rate of
transmission allow us to identify
hotspots how would that work in the
country of 330 million people where
presumably community infection is still
going to take place where this is
asymptomatic where we're not gonna have
45 minute around presumably for most
businesses presumably for most
businesses you're gonna see three four
day five day turnaround at best is it
really realistic to suggest that we can
ramp up testing to the extent that we
could be able to lock this thing down in
in a in a suit in a seriously measurable
way well we're never going to fully lock
this down this is a highly infectious
disease and as you said at the outset a
lot of the spread is from people who are
asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic who
may not present for testing you try to
do the best you can I mean you try to
mitigate large outbreaks and certainly
another epidemic and the most efficient
way to do that is to have a broad
testing regime where people can get
tested very easily so if they have
certainly signs and symptoms of corona
virus they should present to a doctor to
get tested for it but even if they have
mild symptoms that they have cold like
symptoms you want to have testing really
excess
so people can get swapped all the time
to make sure that they're not one of the
people who has coronavirus but it's
mildly symptomatic so that they if they
are they can self isolate they can avoid
family members who might be vulnerable
to the infection that's the way you cut
down on the rate of transmission the
reality is I don't think we need to
scale up testing that much from where we
are right now our capacity right now is
probably about a million tests a week I
think if we got to three million tests a
week capacity that would probably be
sufficient to do what we call sentinel
surveillance basically have enough
testing being done on a regular basis
that if there are outbreaks of any size
you know if there's a couple of hundred
cases within a city you're probably
going to be able to detect it and the
reason I use the number three million is
because there's about 3.8 million
encounters with primary care doctors
every week and so it's not unreasonable
to say that you know for the foreseeable
future for the next six months while
we're worried about another epidemic
everyone who's presenting to a
healthcare provider for routine primary
care regardless of what it's for should
probably get swab for coronavirus if you
had that broad testing in place now
granted that's the selected population
some people are presenting because
they're sick some people presenting
things like just routine health care or
maybe because they sprained their ankle
but if you're testing that broadly it
increases the odds that if there is an
outbreak in a city you're gonna see it
when there's maybe hundreds of cases and
before there's thousands of cases and
when there's hundreds of cases that's
enough to be able to intervene that's a
low enough number that you can actually
intervene to try to contain the outbreak
and not let it become epidemic so when
you talk about containing the outbreak
would that involve locking down that
specific area and how would contact
tracing come into play when it comes to
stuff like that so let's say that you've
been able to identify an outbreak the
outbreak presumably has taken a week to
materialize fully because people have to
infect each other a little bit
can you really back trace contact
tracing to a couple of hundred people in
the city is that really a possibility or
at that point are you looking at you
just lock down that area and you hope
that it sort of Peters out elsewhere
well you don't want to lock down an area
what you want to do is the contact
tracing you want to do what we call case
based interventions try to find people
who are sick and you know if you have
hundreds or even lo thousands of cases
yet you can very efficiently do contact
tracing we do it all the time for things
like measles or multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis so this is sort of the
bread and butter
public health work in fact we were doing
it early on in the case of coronavirus
as well it's just that the number of
infections ended up exhausting our
ability to do this and what what it
isn't in the simplest form is you want
to do two things the first is when
people are infected you want to ask them
to self isolate for the duration of
their illness so they should stay at
homes because they're infectious I think
if we're going to ask people to self
isolate we have to think about what
we're going to do to make sure that
they're compensators so they don't lose
wages and maybe even compensate them
directly for some of the burden of self
isolating we're asking to do that for a
societal good what you what you don't
want is a regime where you're asking
people to self isolate and they're
losing wages and so being diagnosed with
corona virus becomes something that's
punitive so we need to think about that
from a policy standpoint in terms of the
contract retracing when you do identify
positive people then you want to
interview them and find out who they've
been in touch with and you want to get
in touch with those people and offer
them the opportunity to get tested as
well and that's how you can cut down and
spread nothing's gonna be foolproof it
gets back to what we started talking
about with the temperature checks this
is sort of everything Swiss cheese but
if you stack up enough layers of Swiss
cheese eventually you can get something
that's impervious that's the goal here
you're trying to get layers of
protection in place so the least
intrusive measures possible so society
can get back to normal life but you can
have some measure of protection you're
not going to protect against outbreaks
there's going to be isolated outbreaks
this is going to this is a fact of life
we always have outbreaks of infectious
disease what you want to do is protect
against large outbreaks and certainly
epidemic spread on the proportion that
we're having right now the other sort of
Avenue that I wanted to explore here was
the the antibody testing that's been
done we've now had some antibody testing
done in Iceland we've had it done in
Germany there was a town in northern
Italy where they did two antibody
testing and now we have this antibody
tested in in Santa Clara and it tends to
show even in very small kind of ways and
there's a there was a study of pregnant
women in New York City showing that a
multiple of people who are actually
symptomatic have actually had this thing
and that it may be in fact be a very
high multiple which of course is good
news and it's bad news it's good news in
the sense that it really does bring down
the case fatality rate we're saying case
fatality rates that are maybe an order
of magnitude if these studies are
correct at least an order of magnitude
maybe an order of magnitude times to
like 20 times or 30 times higher than
the actual case fatality rate on the bad
that means this thing is SuperDuper
transmissible which means that if lots
of people get it lots of people die even
if the case fatality rate is low with
that said doesn't that just mean then
what we really ought to be doing is
looking at tranching the population a
lot of the measures that seem to have
been taken almost seems to treat
populations as as fluid as though people
who are elderly are getting this at the
same rate of people as people who are
younger or the people start dying from
it the same rate as people who are
younger or the people who are younger or
are as vulnerable we keep hearing from
public health officials things like yes
it's much more dangerous for elderly
people but young people are dying of it
too and that young people are dying of
it too that's true but on a rate basis
it's it's extraordinarily different I
mean if you're if you are 80 to 89
there's maybe a 20% chance that you die
but if you acquire it if you are if you
are below the age of 25 there's almost a
zero percent chance that you died of it
if you acquire it is it is it
responsible to not separate out the
populations every time public health
officials and and media experts and and
members of the government talk about
this thing because if we're talking
about reintroducing people into the
business workplace isn't there a case we
made that we really should be pursuing
in the long run what Sweden has done we
just had to lock down first that
basically if you're young and your
health you put on a mask you social
distance and you go back to work let me
just touch on the first point that you
opened up with about the antibody test
and what the rate of infection is it's
probably the case that we're diagnosing
one in ten or one in 20 infections so
we're missing a lot of mild infections
we're missing a lot of asymptomatic
infections the number of people who are
asymptomatic there's been various
studies that have looked at this and
range from anywhere 20 20 percent of
people on the diamond for instance were
asymptomatic now that's a selected
population the older population so they
might be more likely to become
symptomatic some studies have shown as
many as 50% of people are asymptomatic
most folks are going by the by the
notion that there's probably 25 to 30%
of people who are asymptomatic when you
look at populations as a whole across
the United States it's probably going to
be the case that the overall exposure to
this has been relatively low somewhere
in the order of two to five percent in
Santa Clara where there was an that was
a hot spot I think the study that your
reference showed two point five to four
point six percent positivity so
the exposure on those antibody test was
2.5 24.6%
so relatively low is certainly not the
kind of 50 to 60 percent exposure that
you need to have herd immunity where
it's not going to spread I suspect when
we look at New York we're gonna find
higher rates of exposure so if you look
at the fatalities in New York right now
eleven thousand four hundred and seventy
seven as of yesterday if you assumed
we've only diagnosed I think over a
hundred thousand but less than two
hundred thousand cases in New York but
if you assumed actually that a million
people had corona virus in New York and
we just didn't detect most of them that
still puts the case fatality rate at
over one percent if you assume two
million New Yorkers had it which I think
would be high at this point around
twenty five percent of the New York
population we might get there but I
don't think we're there right now that
would put the case fatality rate at 0.5%
so significantly more than the flu very
high for something that's this that's
this transmissible in terms of the
issues around who's at risk there's a
lot of people at risk for this it's not
just the older populations above 65
there's there's a lot of
hospitalizations for under 65 there's a
lot of people under 65 who are doing
poorly or only surviving up to prolonged
hospitalizations but some of the risk
factors beyond just age or things like
diabetes pulmonary disease can't you
know chemotherapy if you're
immunocompromised heart disease and so
you start to scope in a broader section
of the population ten percent of
population is diabetic obesity seems to
be a risk factor as well and so that
doesn't just cut across the older
populations but younger as well and when
you look at the fatality rates across
the age spectrum it's true that they
spiked up among the older older cohorts
but even for forty five year old and I
paid attention to this ping around there
myself the case fatality rates about ten
times flu so the case fatality rate for
forty five year old is about point two
depending on what study you're looking
at sometimes a little bit higher than
that the case fatality rate for flu in a
45 year olds 0.02 maybe less and so
still ten times you know the case
fatality rate the lethality of flu so
it's it is true that younger people are
doing better than older people but
younger people are still at risk from
this and so I think the notion that you
know if you just sort of
let it loose in 40 and 50 year olds
you're gonna have a lot of morbidity
there too and some mortality but
certainly a lot of morbidity so when you
look at transient populations back in
let's say that you're under 40 and
you're healthy and people are wearing
masks in socially distancing ooh what
Sweden seems to have basically said if
you're older or you're vulnerable it's
your choice but you really should stay
at home and if you are younger yes you
should engage in the social distancing
to prevent exactly the sort of infection
of people who may be vulnerable that
we're talking about to prevent sort of
widespread of this thing but if you're
younger and you want to undergo that
wristband that's basically we're gonna
have to do it seems like that that is
likely to happen with some level of
testing just to identify epidemic
hotspots do we basically look like
Sweden and what Sweden right do you
think to not lock down at the beginning
or we're not gonna be able to judge
until a year has passed and we see what
a second wave looks like yeah I think
it's good I think the being able to
judge whether what we do is right and
wrong is going to take time because we
only we don't yet fully understand the
costs of what we've done I mean there
isn't beyond just the economic cost of
what we've done we've done to try to
break break this epidemic and whether or
not we're able to recover from that in a
timely fashion there's public health
costs to what we've done so you're
weighing the public health cost of the
epidemic against the public health
implications of what we've done if you
look at date of vaccinations
prescriptions are down 80% since the
pandemic started now those those are
some people who aren't going to get back
to knee are we gonna see outbreaks of
measles because of that now people
aren't presenting with heart attacks and
strokes that's not because of not having
heart attacks and strokes but they're
staying home I saw data on people
missing chemotherapy rounds and so those
there's going to be public health
implications from that as well and we're
gonna it's going to take time to measure
the full cost of that now that said this
was a very broad epidemic in the United
States that was a that was we were
losing control of and so the only thing
we had left were these population-based
mitigation steps to try to break that
epidemic I think now that we've done
that now that we're going to be exiting
the epidemic phase of kovat 19 the
United States I think we're going to
move to something more akin to what
you're describing where over the month
of May as we slowly return to work in a
gated fashion initially what what's
going to happen is people who are
vulnerable to this virus because they're
older
they have one or more comorbidities are
going to be asked to stay at home
initially for a week or two while
everyone else goes back to work and we
make sure that we can do that safely
without seeing a resurgence in the virus
because what we want to avoid most of
all is what's happening now in Singapore
and Hong Kong where you're seeing a
second wave I don't think we can afford
to have a second wave in this country we
can't go through what we've just gone
through in terms of the economic costs
of of these stay at home orders and as
of this economic shutdown and so we need
to make sure we get this right speaking
of the second wave in Hong Kong and
Singapore those are those are places
that have fairly heavy testing as well
as contact tracing I mean it's one of
the reasons they're able to walk down
without completely locking down their
economy in Singapore for example and yet
they're seeing a second wave anyway what
do you what do you think is the
possibility that we actually avoid a
fairly significant second wave I mean I
mean really I mean outside of New York
City I can't imagine a situation in
which there isn't some sort of second
wave in New York City simply because of
the population and because of the what I
mean just the population size the
density the fact that everybody is using
the subways you know it's it's it's hard
to see how New York goes back to work
anytime soon but the rest of the country
is not New York which which does suggest
that maybe a federalist solution is the
best solution here this is why the I
think the administration took the
approach that it did where it gave a lot
of discretion to local officials and
governors because this isn't a
one-size-fits-all epidemic in different
parts of the country face different
risks different parts of the country
have different resources in other parts
of the country so if you're a more rural
state you're naturally socially
distancing if you don't have the same
density of population but at the same
time you might not have a good health
care infrastructure so you might be a
more risk from that standpoint you know
it might not be able to sustain an
outbreak and so local officials and
governors need to make those decisions
and we've by and large done that and
you've seen states take different
approaches to how they've even
implemented stay at home orders around
the country and I think we're gonna see
that on the way out of this as well
where certain parts of the country
probably the tri-state area in New York
is going to be slower to go back to work
and open things up versus other parts of
the country where you didn't have
epidemic spread the reality is any part
of the countries that risk for this
because it only takes a handful of index
cases to turn into an epidemic now
getting to the heart of your question I
think you know as we transition in May
we'll slowly transition back to work in
May and June I think it's going to be
you know a six-week we
two two month effort to get get people
back to work I'm hopeful July in August
the depth of the summer are going to be
some kind of backstop against
transmission that I'm there probably is
some seasonal component to this
coronavirus most coronaviruses don't
circulate in the summer now that said
this one is likely to circulate in the
summer because it's so novel we have no
cross immunity but hopefully it doesn't
circulate as readily as people are
outdoors more so the epidemiology of
spread changes and also droplet
transmission becomes less efficient in
the hot humid mud so assuming we can get
through this summer we make a transition
back to work people are naturally
skittish so they're not going back to
all the activities they were doing and
that's going to help break change the
transmission the fact that people just
are going to be more cautious and then
we get into July and August when things
are slower anyway in the summertime I'm
really worried about September I'm
worried about what happens when we come
back in the fall and you have
residential college campuses back in
session schools back in session and
people back in offices and people are
feeling more confident so maybe they're
letting their guard down a little bit
now the mitigating factor there that I'm
hopeful about is that we're going to
have a different toolbox we'll have the
testing in place so we'll be doing that
broad surveillance testing that we
talked about the outset and I'm hopeful
that we'll have one or more therapeutics
that can help rescue people people who
are vulnerable to the infection when
they present to the hospital they can
get a dose of a drug one or more drugs
that can help mitigate the infection and
reduce the chances that they have a
really bad outcome I'm hopeful we'll
have that I think we'll have it we
shouldn't be able to have it if we can
pull through some of the treatments that
are now in development I think one or
more of them are likely to work they're
not going to be cures they're not gonna
be home runs but they don't need to be
it's a very difficult time I think for a
lot of Americans not just because of the
obvious but also because it's a time
when when we have to listen to the
experts but the experts also don't know
a lot about the virus I mean the virus
is a mystery and so one of the one of
the factors that's been sort of a
problem is the criticism of the modeling
so I've looked at for example the UW
model which changed over time in terms
of the the number of because it was it
was Curt fitting I remember I asked you
about this on Twitter because it was
current fitting the the new data that
was coming in was was changing the
number of hospitalizations that were
suggested the number of beds that were
suggested and all the rest people are
obviously critical of that Imperial
model that originally had suggested 2.2
million deaths with no social with no
social distancing or anything at all and
then as soon as the social distancing
kicked in they said okay well this has
changed the curve and so now it's only
gonna be twenty thousand deaths
looking back on some of the models as we
get more information about the the
transmission rate and and the fatality
rate do you think that the models could
have been better was it basically just
people doing the best that they could
why do you think that the models were so
off when it came to the number of ICU
beds and ventilators that would be
necessary in the u-dub model for example
yeah you know people want to think that
the models are dynamic and they're
making all kinds of considerations about
the impact of our policy decisions and
they're not really doing that there as
you said they're they're fitting curves
to lines and they're using some of the
past experience to predict the future
experience and the it's not like
forecasting the weather where you sort
of make the prediction and you go away
and see if it turns out to be correct
you make the prediction and then you're
starting to take policy steps based on
what you're predicting and and that's
gonna ultimately affect the outcome and
that's what happened here you know I
think that there were a bunch of us who
felt that the initial I HIV model and
that's the University of Washington
model you reference and that was the one
I was being closely looked at by the
White House that the initial prediction
predictions around upwards of two
hundred fifty thousand deaths was was
high it felt very high relative to what
you know you could sort of project on
the back of an envelope in the United
States if we were going to get this
under control I think where it is now is
probably more akin to where it's going
to end up I think that the model right
now is predicting around 60,000 deaths
we might end up a little bit below that
we probably have two more weeks of you
know more deaths associated with this
illness at high rates because there's a
delay in time to death here of three to
six weeks and so you have a lot of
people hospitalized now a lot of people
in the intensive care units many of whom
are going to succumb to the infection
the rates of death once you're intubated
is very high related to this infection
but even if you impute those assumptions
you're probably going to get to
something close to where the models are
maybe not quite there maybe a little bit
more but I think the model is immoral
with where this epidemics going to turn
out the the sort of uncertainties for me
two weeks ago and if you go back and
look at my Twitter feed what I was
worried about was some of the states
that were late to implement mitigation
but showed a rising number of cases and
they weren't testing that much so you
were worried you didn't have a great
sense of what the overall background
rate of infection were and those were
states like Georgia and Texas maybe
Louisiana and Florida Alabama I think
that those states Georgia and Texas in
particular we see declining infections
Florida and Louisiana we have a pretty
good handle on the course of the
epidemics there they Louisiana turned
out to be worse than was what was being
anticipated I think Florida is in line
with what many people were anticipating
but Georgia and Texas in particular you
haven't seen an explosion number of
cases and that's all hopeful I think
we're really coming through this as a
country and you're seeing declining
rates of infection everywhere with the
exception of a handful of hotspots where
you're still seeing growth in cases you
know selected counties and some selected
parts of the country so looking at the
possibility of the second wave what
would that look like would it be as
severe as the first wave we know what
the Spanish flu obviously the second way
was a lot more severe than the first
wave as people go back to work if there
is a second wave and if as you say it's
sort of dies off a bit during the summer
people are outdoors more then everybody
goes back to school in September but
Grandma and Grandpa are coming over and
the social distancing has started to go
by the wayside because you've got a
hundred kids in the school and you only
have two rooms then what what exactly do
you fear that a second wave will look
like and over the course of a year until
we hope a vaccine is developed what do
you think is a realistic number for
Americans to have in mind well I'm I'm
really hopeful that we're going to have
much different set of tools and we can
mitigate really large outbreaks or
certainly epidemic spread again but
there is a possibility that you're gonna
see sizable outbreaks within cities and
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to adopt some element of social
distancing within those cities you'll
see maybe schools closed for a week or
two you can see public transportation
closed or you know reduce schedules and
cities you can see orders for businesses
to try to allow employees to telework
may be closing indoor spaces that are
for entertainment only like bars and
restaurants and movie theaters those are
all possibilities if you have a city
that's having a sizable outbreak but I
think we're going to be in a better
position to both detect outbreaks while
they're still small try to contain
outbreaks and adopt some measures
earlier in the course of an outbreak so
you don't get to these really big
outbreaks or epidemic spread again like
we're experiencing right now so you
don't have to go back to what we're
doing now which is basically a national
shutdown simultaneously across the whole
country I think we should be in a much
better position to address this going
forward but you this is going to be a
constant challenge I don't think this
goes away until we get to a vaccine I
think there's always gonna be cases I
think you're gonna have to see spikes in
cases and flare-ups that are going to be
on a regional basis every part of the
country is vulnerable to an outbreak and
this is going to become a fact of life
that we're just gonna learn to live with
I think certain things that we do are
going to change I think our habits are
gonna change how we practice hygiene I
think masks are going to become more
fashionable people are going to be more
conscious of hand-washing
I think a lot of businesses are going to
advertise that they test their workers
or that they clean shared spaces you're
gonna see airlines talking about what
they do on hygiene related to travel
Uber's maybe are going to do that so I
think things are gonna change just like
after 9/11 there were certain things
that changed I don't mean to compare
this to 9/11 at all but after 9/11 we
had certain security features it just
didn't go away we never took our shoes
off in airports we never handed in ID
cards we went into buildings there's
gonna be certain things that change
around society that we never did before
that we're gonna do now going forward
because of our heightened awareness of
the risk of spread the good news if
there is any is that we're gonna get
some some benefits for that not just in
terms of reduced risk from Corona Vice
but we'll probably have shortened flu
seasons we'll probably have less
morbidity more death and disease less
death and disease from flu because all
the things that we're doing to cut down
the risk of corona virus are going to
cut down the risk of transmission of flu
and we're oddly complacent about flu we
let flu infect far too many people each
year and if we can cut down a rates of
flu transmission that's going to have
some real economic benefits it's going
to be captured in the forms of four most
significant productivity improvements
that are that are going to be measurable
so you sit on the reopening the country
council for the president how has that
been
how's that been working how does that
council actually operate well I think
it's more of an advisory board and I
don't know how they're interfacing with
other members of on that council but
I've had discussions with various people
in the White House about aspects of you
know both the public health response to
the epidemic right now as well as steps
to try to reopen work and restart the
economy and I published a number of
papers a lot of the most of the private
advice that I'm giving is the same as
the public advice that I'm writing about
so I'm number of papers that mirror the
kind of private advice that I'm giving
the administration on steps to you know
effectively and efficiently but also
safely reopen the economy and do it in a
staged fashion so we can mitigate the
risk of you know another outbreak so
looking at sort of how this is all been
treated by the public and in the media
and how everything becomes very
polarized very quickly a lot of time has
been spent you know kind of looking
retrospectively what the administration
could have done better well I've looked
at obviously the timeline here and it
seems to me that aside from you you
you're calling for pretty serious
measures in late January a lot of people
were saying that corners might be
serious but the kind of measures that
they were actually proposing didn't
start to get serious until early March
by mid March the country was already
looking at locked down if you look at
Europe a lot of places we're not issuing
full lockdown orders until about the
same time France and Germany my friend
Germany was early France was a little
bit later France was like mid
mid-february sorry mid March already UK
was about the same time as the United
States how do you gauge the the America
America's federal and and state response
to because there were a lot of state and
local officials who also didn't get on
the game until early March I remember
being kind of bewildered as to why the
mayor of Los Angeles was allowing the LA
Marathon to go forward on March 8th I
believe it was well at the same time
everybody was starting to take this
thing very seriously how would you gauge
the United States's response
retrospectively well the kinds of things
that I was calling for in January and
even into February was more diagnostic
screening III had written a number of
articles in January talking about the
importance of getting the clinical labs
in the academic labs in the games
starting to get them stood up to do
testing and what I wanted to get into
place at that time was what we would
call a sentinel surveillance system and
the idea would have been that for people
who present with flu
flu-like symptoms and get tested for flu
and are negative for flu you'd want to
be testing those samples for coronavirus
and and had you had that in place my
belief was at the time that you would
have been able to detect outbreaks of
corona virus earlier while they were
still small about of the people who
present with flu-like symptoms and get
tested for flu only about thirty percent
on any given week and it varies over the
course of the flu season actually test
positive for the fluid so the question
is what are the rest have oftentimes
they have add no virus or RSV
respiratory syncytial virus
or they might have another corona virus
but if you were actively testing for
corona virus at that time in January and
February my belief was you might have
been able to detect outbreaks and in
fact the first outbreak that we detected
was in Seattle and we detected it from
some testing that was going on by a
group of researchers of people who were
presenting with flu-like symptoms and
testing negative for flu they just
started randomly testing those samples
and they discovered there was an
outbreak there which gets to the second
part of a question which is how did we
do the reality is I think when when we
look retrospectively the cities and
states were slow to implement mitigation
steps here you know New York I think's
done an admirable job over the over the
recent weeks and and faced an outbreak
of a proportion that nope nowhere else
in the world maybe even Italy has faced
the same proportion of you know
infection that New York's faced but they
they were slow to implement mitigation
steps in the city there's no question
about that slow to close the schools
slow to close the bars you know I think
in particular Seattle was very slow to
implement mitigation steps and I was you
know commenting on that about at the at
the time they had a sizable outbreak and
they weren't closing recreational indoor
recreational venues like theaters and
restaurants they they weren't closing
their schools well past the point that I
think other cities ultimately made
similar decisions to do those things
Seattle hadn't done that they were
allowing cruise ships to leave from the
Port of Seattle
well after the point that we had
multiple cruise ships with major
outbreaks on those cruise ships and in
fact there was a study out this week
that looked at cases of corona virus in
the state of Connecticut where they
sequenced those and they found that I
think they sequenced seven or eight
different different strains of the virus
from different people
they found that they were related to
clusters that were ultimately originated
in Seattle in Washington State and so
the upshot is that Seattle ended up
seeding a lot of parts of the nation and
we're probably going to find that to be
the case New York it seems was seeded by
European travelers Seattle was probably
seeded by travelers from China before
the travel restrictions were put in
place but other parts of the country was
seeded by Americans they were seeded by
New Yorkers and people from Seattle and
Troy and Chicago traveling to other
parts of the nation including the south
so final question for you as we look at
reopening you've mentioned mid-june to
midnight amid June for the reopening
obviously the president is pushing hard
to faster in a wide variety of ways what
do you what do you think is the the
timeline for various states because it
is going to differ pretty widely by
region what do you think a realistic
timeline looks like by States and and by
industry for example right well look I
think some states are going to be much
sooner than that I think you know the
president talks about some states
perhaps getting people back to work end
of April early May I think some states
are gonna be able to do that safely
because they've had less spread they
their health care system isn't exhausted
they do have good testing in place
remember this isn't sort of a binary
switch it's not we all go back to work
the same day different states have had
made different decisions about who isn't
working so for example my state
gardeners are working and some
construction crews are working so people
who work outdoors have continued to work
but in other states that isn't the case
and so you could see some states making
decisions to allow people who work
outdoors to go back to work much sooner
but then you know office workers go back
a little later people can't naturally
social distance on the job so it's going
to be a gradual evolution of back to
work over the course of the month I
think some states that haven't had large
outbreaks that have good capacity in
place probably going to make decisions
early and made to start doing that that
gradual return to work
I think states that have been hard hit
like the Northeast are gonna go to make
decisions much later I think the New
York tri-state area probably not likely
to see them start to send people back to
work till mid May I think that's a
reasonable target and initially that's
gonna look like you know stage fashion
they're going to identified categories
of work that can go back they're going
to tell people who are older or have
serious comorbidities that could could
make them more prone to a bad
out come to stay home for a little extra
time another week or two they're going
to encourage businesses that can allow
people to telework to continue they're
going to put in place guidelines on how
to create social distancing at work
things like you know you can't have
meetings above a certain size you want
to create physical separation closed
spaces where people congregate they're
going to put in place guidelines for
things like questionnaires when people
return to work or fever checks as you
know because they again to your original
question at the outset of this they're
not foolproof but they're additive
they're there another layer of
protection so you're gonna see all of
those things factored in and you're
going to see a staged approach of
sending people back to work where you're
gonna send a group back to work you're
gonna wait a week or to measure to make
sure there's no uptick in infections
within that region and then send another
group back to work so I think this is
going to be a gradual evolution that
plays out over the course of May and
June it's gonna start in early May for
some states probably mid May for other
states but I think by mid-may most
states are going to be contemplating
some some back to work regime and doing
it and hopefully as careful of fashion
as possible so that we can you know
mitigate the risk of a resurgence of
this dr. Gotlieb thanks so much for
being on the program really appreciate
the time sir thanks a lot you can hear
me talk with dr. Gottlieb about China
and their faults in the outbreak if you
only go over to Daley we're calm if you
want to hear that just head on over to
Daley wire comm and click subscribe next
we're gonna be speaking with Steve
Forbes but first let's talk about your
sleep quality it's hard to come by sleep
these days when you do lie down on that
mattress it is very important that you
actually be comfortable so why not have
a mattress personalized for you well you
can do all of this with helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or firm bed with helix
no more confusion no more compromising
hulex sleep is rated the number one
mattress by GQ and Wired magazine CNN
called it the most comfortable mattress
that they've ever slept on Neelix has a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights at risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will just head on
over to helix sleep comm slash been take
that two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
they'll give you the best sleep of your
life I know because I sleep on a helix
sleep mattress every single night and my
goodness when my body hits that bed I am
out like a light because that mattress
was made just for me also because my
kids wipe me out helix is offering
to 200 bucks off all mattress orders for
our listeners today up to 200 bucks off
at helix sleep comm slash Ben that's
helix sleep comm slash Ben you really
should prioritize your mattress quality
because you are gonna be spending an
awful lot of time on it
helix sleep comm slash Ben get up to 200
bucks off today helix lucam slash Ben
[Music]
Steve Forbes is chairman and
editor-in-chief of Forbes media a site
synonymous with money he has been called
on along with dr. Ghali to serve as a
main thought leader on the opening our
country counsel for President Trump he's
the co-author of reviving America about
how repealing Obamacare and replacing
the tax code will restore hope and
prosperity
Steve's newest project is the podcast of
what's ahead where he engages top
newsmakers politicians and pioneers in
Business and Economics and challenges
traditional conventions Steve Forbes
thanks so much for joining the program
really appreciate it first of all you're
now on the president's reopening our
country Economic Council how is that
council actually operating in practice
what they're doing is just taking input
from a number of people you read about
the phone calls they did marathon calls
they did a couple of days ago for around
the country as part of those so you just
provide input and what I like though is
the way that this president whether it's
that activity or what he does at night
with those oppressors is the way he
always acknowledges the private sector
and how critical that is I think that's
the first presence of Toronto Reagan
who's going out of his way to say this
is how we make good things happen
especially in an emergency so Steve how
exactly should we be weighing economic
interests and public health interests
here the president released his plan
this week for reopening the country he
mainly leaves it to Governors which is
the appropriate response because this is
still a federalist country and
localities do vary widely in terms of
how they are going to treat this thing
with that said there's been this real
push for lockdowns to be extraordinarily
severe and lasts a really long time and
even the White House plan suggests that
widespread testing is going to need to
take place I'm wondering realistically
how that's going to ramp up and whether
it's going to be effective given the
fact that they're now all sorts of
studies suggesting really widespread
prevalence of this thing in a sense
manic fashion well this is what happens
when you just focus on one thing and
this is a terrible disease you don't
want to get it affects your lung can
affect your heart your brain everything
else not just a traditional love virus
and so a good response was needed
however we also have the fact that when
you're cooped up when you're confined
when you're businesses are being
destroyed when you have 20 to 30 million
people who are going to be out dori 22
million out of jobs probably another 8
or 10 million before this thing is over
the psychological costs the mental costs
what you're going to see an addiction
alcohol consumption abuse at home the
the live question is when does those
lines cross and I think they have
crossed other than certain hotspots like
New York I live in New Jersey which is
probably the worst area right now at
this particular time but that's
different from other parts of the
country so a variated approach is
absolutely appropriate and while we're
not going to test everyone I wish they
would do much more on testing like they
have with ventilators and other things
so the people can go out and have some
reassurance that by golly they don't
have it that they can in five minutes
find out if they do have it and what we
hope to have in the next few months and
this is where I wish they'd put really a
real ramp up on it to have a test on
this Cove 19 be as routine as taking
your blood pressure so that you can
periodically see do you have this thing
and I think the great news today from
gilead that that looks like we might get
a vaccine far sooner than we anticipated
all this goes to show when you apply
real brain power this thing can be done
quickly but what really annoys me is the
way the federal government and this is
Congress especially but also the Federal
Reserve has been laggard in getting real
aid to small businesses we know that
first fund just ran out Congress of
Nancy Pelosi we're not eating her $20
ice cream is a blocking getting another
250 billion dollars and the Federal
Reserve has been dragging its feet on
this so-called Main Street lending
program putting in crazy restrictions
like high fees high interest rates and
the like you got to throw caution to the
wind and just get the money out we can
clean it up afterwards but when they
talk about stimulus you want to have an
economy out there that you can reach
stimulate and that's where I think on
the small business side they're lagging
it's an ideological level there's been a
lot of criticism of conservatives
suddenly we're all socialists goes the
cry from people on the Left might take
on this has been that this is basically
a governmental taking what we've seen
here is the government coming in and
destroying people's businesses maybe for
good reason maybe maybe in overblown
fashion and that if you destroy
somebody's business for a public purpose
without just compensation is actually a
violation of the takings Clause of the
Constitution that the government
actually does have to compensate you for
destroying your business forcibly the
way they've destroyed literally hundreds
of thousands of businesses across the
United States how do you think
conservatives and libertarians should
look at programs like the ones that are
currently being espoused well this is
insurance this is lifelines these are
not permanent to programs and should not
be permanent programs and that's going
to get to a real fight in this fall one
of these key elections in American
history who have them every forty years
the last big big one was 1980 what kind
of country do we want to be where do we
want to go in the future I think things
have happened in such a way the
landscape is changing so much we're
going to be able to do things if we push
to make positive moves forward that we
haven't before but in the meantime
anything you can do to hit people who
are hurt be by government action not
because of their mistakes or something
like that is absolutely fitting and
proper and one of the things I've been
pushing with the president as others is
to suspend for a year the payroll tax
fifteen percent that's a trillion
dollars you don't know administrative
cost you just don't collect the tax and
what that means is working Americans get
a five hundred billion dollar raise over
the next twelve months making forty
thousand dollars a year that's a three
thousand dollar raise employers get a
five hundred billion dollar reduction in
labor cost so you keep people on longer
more willing to hire people that's
instant and by golly it has a enormous
short-term impact so those are the kind
of things we should be doing massive
programs to get the and the fed just
shovel II have the bank shovel out money
to small businesses get this payroll tax
suspension and have a sensible way of
reopening the economy my area may be a
laggard but other parts of the country
can open up and we will recover there's
a we've seen already the pent-up energy
in this country people wanting to get
out there do things make things happen
and it turns out on
what Russia and China think in Iran
thinks that were a nation in decline
were still a very strong nation with a
good civil of society out there despite
everything when it comes to rebuilding
business and the sorts of loans that
should be available in how we determine
you know who should get a loan and who
should not so that the basic rule right
now has been if you were damaged by
government action then you get a loan on
the other side of that there is a case
to be made that there are going to be
some fairly large systemic changes to
the American economy at least in the
mid-to in the short to mid-term in the
United States travel industry is going
to get absolutely decimated we know the
hotel industry has been decimated we
know that that restaurants for example
are being decimated they've been told
that they can only go delivery only and
for the foreseeable future it is very
likely that states across the country
are going to be forcing social
distancing in restaurants which means
that if you run a small bodega that only
has four tables you know only have one
table which means that you're in serious
trouble with all of that said it doesn't
mean that a lot of the businesses that
are currently taking out loans
yes we're filling them in for damage
that's been done by the government but
at the same time they're very likely to
fail after the economy comes back online
if there are systemic changes in the way
that the market itself is structured and
the way that demand itself is structured
how should we balance those risks well
there's no question real damages are
going to be done and that's why the
length of these loans should be long not
instead of in two years or four years do
ten years and try to make sure as many
of these entities that can survive can
survive and the criterion is very simple
this is why the community banks have
been playing such a key role one they're
getting the money out faster than the
big ones but number two they know which
of their customers were solvent and
which weren't solvent before the crisis
and if the Federal Reserve backstops and
says keep those people going as long as
you think it's a prudent to do so and
will backstop you we won't gig you in
terms of regulatory actions so yes
they'll be damaged but we can minimize
the damage and in terms of social
distancing and the like this is where
testing is very important we're doing
about 130,000 150,000 tests a day we
should be doing a million million and a
half tests a day because people want to
interact with other people and if you
know you don't have the virus or you
know you've got an immunity to the virus
or finding out that there's various
gradations of immunity I never knew that
before
we can test for that if people have some
assurance that they they can get a clean
bill of health
and with the
this is where we're hydroxychloroquine
and other treatments are out there that
even if you get it you can be a get a
good treatment effective treatment
within three to six days so it's not
perfect in the real world but as more
than one doctor has said when we when we
pull out of this lockdown there's gonna
be deaths and whether you do it or you
don't and I think we're reaching the
point where in much of the country we've
got to open up it's not going to be
perfect Democrats are gonna blame every
year Cova 19 death on Donald Trump he
plotted in Trump Tower you know all that
kind of nonsense but it's gonna be there
but that so be it most of the American
people know what what happened and also
to in terms of people worrying about
waste Treasury's worried about well
we're gonna lose a lot of money in these
loans so what when you're in a war and
this is the equivalent of war there's
gonna be a lot of waste there gonna be a
lot of mistakes made and afterwards you
can clean it up but first you got to
deal with the crisis at hand and that's
that should be the criteria not trying
to behave like a bureaucratic banker in
normal times this is not normal times
not by a longshot
when it comes to how we fix this when
this is all done so let's say a lot of
money is lost or this presumably there
are a lot of loans that will just be
defaulted and and the government will
eat the loans obviously the Federal
Reserve is now injecting trillions of
dollars into the system where they're
supposed to be injecting trillions of
dollars into the system they're supposed
to be the weren't one of the theories
that that's been bandied about by folks
on the left elizabeth warren famously
was pushing this was modern monetary
theory which is basically the idea that
the dollar is a magical tree and that
you can just continue to spend money and
at no point will the bill actually come
due well this is accelerated the the
sort of support for things like that
because we are spending without limit
and without apparent end we were before
I mean we were already spending enormous
amount of money we didn't have now we
are radically ramping that up and then a
lot of folks on the Left who sort of
want to make that permanent are saying
well look there's still appetite for
American bonds there's the American
dollar remains strong there is an
alternative to the American dollar what
do you say to people who say okay well
listen we're spending internally now why
can't we just spend eternally in the
future and restructure our entire
economy on this basis
yeah toothfairy monetary theory doesn't
work just look at Germany in the early
1920s or Venezuela today people still
trust the dollar because there's no
there's still a very strong economy here
in the United States and
terms of how we should be financing this
stuff yes there is a very real danger of
inflation down the road the Fed doesn't
know much about inflation even though
it's in the business of trying to come
combat it it doesn't know how to combat
it that's why one of the things that
should be done is for the government to
float 100-year bonds with say 2% coupon
that way you tap existing savings you
don't print the money in effect you
exactly you you and mobilize existing
savings here and around the world to
finance these temporary programs
that's not inflationary it's a cost but
it's not inflationary and that's the
real danger how do you finance all of
these rescue programs there's a right
way to do it in a wrong way I just get
the feeling and you look at the gold
price above $1,700 an ounce it's sort of
signaling maybe the Fed doesn't know how
to deal with it and this crisis is over
and we have all of this liquidity out
there how to make sure we keep an
economy going without resurgence of
inflation now and when we look at the
white house plan one of the things that
actually concerns me is that it might
actually be too restrictive in some ways
meaning that in order for states to
start to release lock down there's a
suggestion there has to be a 14 day
period of decline in the number of
diagnosed cases or at least in the
number of cases as a percentage of the
total number of tests that are that are
being taken and I wonder if that's not
too optimistic specifically because one
of the things that you could easily see
happening is a 14 day decline
day one we open up and magically because
now people are out there infecting each
other the numbers go back up again does
that imply a renewed lockdown and then
on a sort of general level you've been
looking at various governors and how
they treat this thing there does seem to
be a fairly wide differential between
governor's in how they are treating this
sort of stuff obviously Gavin Newsom in
California has been heavily restrictive
andrew cuomo I think a lot more
understandably because New York is the
epicenter California really has not been
hard hit but New York obviously is
treating this thing very strictly Mike
DeWine in Ohio is treating this thing
very strictly and then you have in
Florida not as strict in Texas not as
strict what do you make of the various
governor's responses and are you afraid
that the the White House guidelines may
in fact lead to lock downs that are
actually too long rather than too short
no I think it gives a wide latitude and
this was a great compromise you might
say over the fight who makes know who
has the final authority okay governors
it's
up to you and you see the federalist
system at the federal system at work you
mentioned it you're here you also
Michigan we have a person there who if
you go in and will buy hand sanitizer
and buy a pack of seeds you can get
fined $1,000 and if you go out in a
motorboat you can go to jail but if you
go around and a UV vehicle roaring
through the woods not so here it's okay
and you see these varied responses but
the nice thing about it is we're gonna
see what works and what doesn't work for
example the governor of a South Dakota
got slammed because there was an
outbreak she hasn't locked down the
state formally well it turns out it's a
meatpacking plant and she couldn't have
closed it anyway because it's considered
a absolutely essential thing food yes
and the rest of the states doing fine so
I think you're going to see governors
because they want to please their people
are going to take a varied approach and
people I think understand that if you
get a brief surge it doesn't mean you
have to lock down you don't have to
smother the economy you can focus on
specific areas and you look at the
mortality tables I saw it in a paper the
other day comparing South Korea Spain
and other countries well no surprise yes
there are some young people have been
hit with this thing but by golly no
surprise those of us are above 60 65
especially 80 to 89 the mortality tables
if you get this disease are absolutely
frightening
razza few younger not so you're going to
see much more I think nuanced and
sophisticated approach and this is where
testing will be helpful massive testing
will be helpful you can find out whether
you may be having the thing yeah I'd
like to just taking your blood pressure
from time to time so I think that kind
of ingenuity nuanced approach is the
only way you can go and instead of this
one-size-fits-all so some of us are
gonna be slower than others but hey
we're a big country and we're not all
the same do you have any window into
into practically speaking how the
testing would be rolled out so everybody
keeps talking about testing and we're
doing 150,000 tests today you mentioned
earlier you'd love to see it at 10 times
that realistically speaking is that a
thing that's going to happen in the near
future especially the answer the answer
is yes who ever would have thought that
ventilators
that companies could make the switch and
do ventilators habit came up with this
five-minute 15-minute test who who had
heard about three or four weeks ago they
were there working on it and apparently
there other companies have similar kind
of technology so if you focus on
redirecting resources to a few specific
areas during this emergency you can get
a testing at a very high level and again
I think that Korea creates a comfort
level that you can go out there and I
think when we get more data in on the
vaccine that the Gilead may have that
looks like it's got real promise we know
hydroxychloroquine especially they were
do it early in in the thing it has had
some very encouraging results in France
and elsewhere you're going to have other
things coming out 70 tests are already
underway for vaccines so I think that
people will start to get a comfort level
especially younger people now people in
my age bracket may not be so free but
you know that's a one on one one of the
perils of a living Walker realistically
speaking what do you think the the final
date is going to be for various states I
know that obviously your ballparking
this thing president Trump see us if I
may first there may be some reopening
even governor DeWine in Ohio is
suggesting that there's gonna be some
reopening of businesses by May first by
what point do you think that most people
are gonna be heading back to their jobs
I think by the end of the month
everyone's sort of geared mentally
towards it that there'll be where it can
be movement in that direction now I live
in New Jersey we're probably the worst
area right now in the country so it's
probably not going to be May first but
in other parts of the country and we're
gonna see within states Texas is a big
State Dallas was shut down more than
other parts of the state so you're gonna
see variations within states and so we I
think we will
I think May first let's call it Mayday a
positive May Day where Americans are
going to be liberated and in a positive
way and start to rebuild and it's again
not one size fits all we're just too big
of a country for even entertaining that
the steve forbes really appreciate your
time thanks so much in the state healthy
and safe you too thank you Steve Forbes
and I also discussed what level of risk
Americans should be willing to undergo
when they go back to work
you want to hear his answers to those
questions become a member of our daily
wire comm just go to daily wire comm
click Subscribe and now you are part of
the team well hope you have a wonderful
Sunday we will see you all here tomorrow
this is the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special
[Applause]
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Katie Swinton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Manor
post-production is supervised by Alex's
and Garo editing is by Jim Nicol audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo the venture Pierrot shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]